uh after that we have our discussion
session for about half an hour from 4 to
4:30 um so um the next talk will be
given by my colleague mayor Nik uh who
will talk about scallops and other
Seafood hi everyone uh yeah thanks B um
so I'll be talking about uh this uh
programming language and compiler that
we have been building over the last uh 3
years um on this uh exciting topic
called uh neuros symbolic uh
programming um as a disclaimer I'm a
programming languages researcher mostly
consuming uh all the cool stuff that uh
folks in databases and uh uh AI have
been uh doing so so you won't see much
in terms of novelty but you'll see a lot
of interesting synergies and and uh you
know empirical results that come from
uh importing good theory uh from other
fields let me first uh motivate uh the
need for neuros
symbolic uh programming uh so there are
these two prevalent paradigms of modern
programming uh as all of you know so
there's so these are commonly called
system one and system two by noted
psychologist Daniel kanaman in his book
uh Thinking Fast and Slow um so if you
see uh the system one is uh uh is is
deep learning where uh you have a lot of
benefits um for example uh you know you
have uh Subs symbolic knowledge uh what
that means is you have uh uh you know
meaning associated with say a name Tom
that likely is a male and so on right um
um there's open domain knowledge so you
don't have to uh write encode everything
explicitly uh they're good at rapid
reasoning handling noise and naturalness
and and what we nowadays see with
Foundation models is in context learning
or more accurately uh prompt
engineering the other hand uh we have uh
classical algorithms which is system two
uh where uh you can uh explicitly encode
knowledge and avoid the and get uh more
data efficient Solutions can also do uh
complex reasoning uh you know so things
like uh multihop reasoning using
recursion but also negation aggregation
and so on which traditionally deep
learning is isn't great at you have
other benefits like
interpretability modular reasoning and
uh better generalizability right now
traditionally these two systems um don't
talk to each other um very well um um
but but we do want features of both for
many AI applications right and so that
has given rise to this feere field
called uh neuros symbolic uh
programming um now this term means
slightly different things to different
people um and so I'm going to uh Define
more specifically what it means to us um
that there is uh a much richer taxonomy
of of different styles of neuros
symbolic programming that we don't uh
necessarily
Encompass uh but I will show you that at
least this form that we consider uh is
uh uh interesting enough to write a lot
of uh useful applications right so what
I've shown here is uh a picture of uh
the three uh approaches uh before
proceeding to why it is uh hard to
combine deep learning and classical
algorithms in a single
system so in deep learning uh the much
of the success comes from um from uh
gradient descent algorithms right for uh
Computing this for back propagating the
loss uh to to learn the parameter Theta
of this uh neural model right um X and Y
are uh in in these double boxes
indicating that you have supervision on
them right um on the other hand
classical algorithms such as this
program P um um can um typically work on
structur data which I'm going to
indicate with r
okay and in neur symbolic uh this is a
simple neuros symbolic program where uh
there's initially a neural component M
Theta uh which takes input X produces an
intermediate uh representation R which
is
structured uh which in turn is fed to a
classical algorithm P to produce an
output y right um and we have a gradient
descent here Dr by D Theta but we'd also
like uh to somehow back propagate the
loss uh um across this program uh this
discrete program P okay um and even
though this looks like a supervised
learning setting we have actually used
neuros symbolic uh programming in many
different settings that I'll show you
today including RL um and even
unsupervised learning with Foundation
models so what are some of the
challenges that we tackled in building
scallop right so the first question is
what is the the the symbolic
representation to use for R right and
the second is what is the the reasoning
language uh for programs P right as you
can imagine there's a lot of different
choices uh for these uh
decisions most importantly um how can we
uh obtain an automatic and efficient
differentiable reasoning engine to learn
this uh Dy by Dr under what we call
algorithmic supervision right what that
means is you not given supervision on R
right and that makes this whole problem
more challenging you only have
supervision end to endend on end to
endend observable input output data X
and Y okay but not on sort of
intermediate data R and this makes sense
for a lot of applications if you think
of an Healthcare application right you
have data about a patient uh all of
their lab measurements and so on um and
you have some outcome why of say a
treatment
um but um even an expert clinician might
might well not have time to label every
intermediate piece of information or
might not even know how to label it
right even if they
could so um so that makes this problem
uh um particularly
challenging we also have two other uh
challenges here we'd like to tailor
learning uh uh of uh of this this uh
Computing Dy by Dr by by different
applications characteristics okay at
this point we are looking at approximate
algorithms uh which go along well with
you know gradient descent which is
already
approximate um and lastly uh we'd like
to integrate with all the existing
training pipelines this is more of an
empirical uh challenge here we don't
want to reinvent something like pytorch
and so we'd like to uh reuse all the
existing models and and and training
pipeline
in
SC so here are some of the design
decisions that we made um much of this
borrows from work uh by other
researchers we were particularly
inspired by deep proog but would later
learn that uh there was work by many
other researchers as well and our main
contribution here was really using data
log and putting all of this together in
a in a practical uh system right so the
first uh designed decision here was to
use a relational representation for R
right and and I don't need to tell a
database Community uh about the about
how relational the relational model has
withstood the test of time it is it is
you know it can it can represent very
general forms of data you know arbitrary
graphs um um you know there are many
other nice properties about relations as
I will show you when we tag tupal with
probabilities and and more General kinds
of information how uh this relational
representation is really
helpful um the second is the the choice
of the language for p and here we use a
data log based language we started out
literally with data log but it has grown
over uh the the years uh we have support
for algebraic data types foreign
functions and so on um actually it is at
this point uh Turing complete so
depending on what subset of a language
you use um you know you get different
guarantees um perhaps the most
interesting piece here for uh this
audience is uh we accidentally
discovered Provence semirings we were
playing with different kinds of tags uh
and eventually realized that they uh
could uh that they were one one could
generalize them uh in this very elegant
work uh which was mentioned at the
beginning of this workshop on provenant
semi
rings and I'll show you the different
semi rings that we have uh in my talk
and lastly we uh uh have uh you know uh
integration with both pytorch and Jax so
uh pytorch for uh getting models uh that
might be pre-trained and so on that me
invite want to fine tune but also for uh
um Computing the loss here using
something like
Jacks so a pretty usable framework um
and to end um with lots of moving
pieces let me give a a simple motivating
example of the kinds of things we can do
with scallop right this is a a a simple
uh strategy game called Pac-Man it's
actually a simplified version which is
called Static Pac-Man as in the ghosts
are not moving the setup is as follows
there's this grid of 5x5 cells right um
each time in each instance of this game
uh we uh randomly assign these ghosts
the Pac-Man agent and the goal uh in
different cells right and the as I said
the ghosts don't move and so the goal is
to uh
learn um to uh for this agent this this
Pacman to learn to reach the goal
without hitting any of the the ghosts
right um we set this up as a as a simple
RL uh reinforcement learning problem um
and we use a a simple uh model here
which is dqn deep Q
networks um to to train this uh uh agent
right so the Baseline here is an
endtoend uh neural model a convolutional
neural network uh which is not given
supervision on uh which cells contain
ghosts or the or the goal post or the
the Pacman itself right all of this is
the intermediate repres presentation to
be learned the only supervision one gets
is after an entire game episode where uh
either the Pac-Man reached the goal uh
so you get a reward of one or it didn't
and in which case it gets a reward of
zero
right and we formulate this problem in
scallop by decomposing it into a neural
model right which is doing sort of this
low-level perception so the goal of the
neural model is to Simply learn um um
what each cell might contain right and
there are four choices it can either be
empty or it can contain a ghost or it
can contain the the packman itself or it
can contain the goal okay so these are
the four
choices now this neural model um uh
outputs these choices to a logic program
in
scallop um whose goal is to do the path
planning okay so in summary instead of
having a monolithic neural network which
is trying to learn and to end how to uh
do both uh entity extraction and path
planning we decompose this task into
entity extraction which is sort of
low-level perception that is best done
by a neural module and uh a logic
program a classical algorithm which does
the path planning right and at each step
the goal is to decide whether the
Pac-Man should move up down right or
left right but you'll get the reward
only after an entire episode of around
uh 20 steps
okay so um um here's our uh empirical
result in in just 50 such episodes uh
with this scallop program that I showed
you we can get an accuracy of
99.4% whereas if you do this with a
baseline of end to end neural you get a
much lower accuracy and it requires over
uh 50,000 episodes right there's some uh
hand waving here this is not entirely a
fair comparison right because we have
written a domain knowledge using uh
logic rules I probably skipped over the
the program itself so here goes um so
this is our our syntax uh for uh our our
data log based language for in this case
for path planning so the goal here is to
compute uh the next action right one of
these four
choices uh and that in turn depends on
on uh whether there's a path from an
adjoining position where the Pac-Man
currently is to the goal right and the
definition of a path is itself a
recursive predicate um uh it's a path
that uh does not collide with uh any any
of the ghosts right and that is encoded
using what we call Safe cells okay any
questions so
far okay so um uh um so the programmer
writes this discrete program without any
probabilities and so on um but what you
will see happening under the hood when
when when when both at training and
inference time is a neural model will
compute these predicates such as actor
goal and enemy only with different
degrees of certainty right so in some
sense we have all of these possible
words being tracked simultaneously by uh
uh the the scallop uh engine okay and
all of that computation will be done
through uh tags which you don't see uh
here uh at the level of the values that
are being propagated may can I ask a
very question on this is there a notion
of a shortest path or it's any path or
how great question so uh it is uh so so
here we say any path but if I understand
this correctly the tags will penalize
paths that are longer okay and Cycles in
the path you
will like I I
think so so uh okay so so let me get
into the semi Rings okay so the short
answer is the tags will track uh you
know will will be tracking a finite
amount of information so they won't uh
necessarily compute all you know Parts
with cycles and so
on yes um in this example the network is
responsible for extracting the state of
the program and then you have a you have
your actual program to kind of like
perform your logic like Network extracts
like action information or
something so the neural network only
extracts okay so the question was
whether the neural network extracts
these predicts these actions right it
did if it did
framewor so that is the Baseline that I
was showing you that you don't have a
logic program so the neural network is
taking in this this grid of pixels 200
by 200 pixels and producing one of these
four outputs or rather distribution over
these four outputs so that is the
Baseline I mean if you were using that
then you wouldn't need scallop right I
here we are trying to show you that you
can actually give more data efficient
and robust and so on okay by the way
this program which is learned it
generalizes very nicely to much larger
grids even 25 by 25 so so you see um
whereas a network which was trained end
to end would probably not generalize
well to other grids grid sizes okay um
so let me briefly talk about uh what is
going on in the scallop compiler uh so
we have this differentiable reasoning
framework U First a preview of our
entire uh compiler so the the surface
syntax looks like this in this case you
know it even has uh limited forms of
quantifiers um we have a a front end
which produces these abstract syntax
trees um and and there are several
passes here for type inference and so on
then we have a back end where uh which
is based on extended data log where we
do a lot of optimizations including
query planning and magic set
Transformations and so on and finally we
have this relational algebra machine or
Ram um uh uh which is what is actually
um executed at training and inference
time right and this is what the
equivalent uh scalop RAM program looks
looks like for that high level
constraint so uh where does prominence
come in um so the semantics of Ram uh is
essentially just extended relational
algebra uh which is well the semantics
of data log uh we have implemented uh a
very general framework for tracking
Provence right um and this is inspired
by the work on provenant semi- rings um
that was mentioned at the beginning of
this Workshop um and we even have this
very clean interface to Define new
Provence uh structures right and this
was again covered in the original
tutorial but briefly there's this tag
space that you have to Define yourself
um and then uh various operations for
disjunction conjunction negation and
saturation right I've shown one instance
of this abstract structure here which we
call maximum probabilities uh here the
set of tags is real numbers between zero
and one um and and disjunction is Max
conjunction is min and so on and so
forth
okay um if you apply um this maxman prob
to a particular rule uh during the
execution of uh the program I showed you
let's say the rule which computes
whether a cell X comma Y is safe okay so
it is safe it's if it is indeed a grid
cell okay a cell in the grid in the 5x5
grid and uh we do not believe that
there's an enemy in the cell right so
this is the standard semantics of data
log of discrete data log okay untagged
semantics so let us say that in 1 comma
2 and 2 comma 3 are two different grid
cells and let us say the enemy is in the
cell 2 comma 3 then we know how to
compute this difference so that's just
the tupal 1 comma 2 right but in the
tagged semantics something much uh
richer is happening which is is that we
have these tags T1 T2 and T3 now and
they are T they they are propagated here
uh along with the output values of each
rule um and once you use a particular uh
provenant semi ring in this case the
maxim Min prob uh we can for example say
that um in this case we believe the
enemy is in cell 2 comma 3 with a
probability of 0.2 coming from the
convolutional neural network right and
so now you can imagine every cell has
some probability of an enemy being there
um and accordingly you can now get
estimates of um um uh which cells are
safe
okay yes go
ahead so the difference with problem
with is that use this fuzzy logic way of
propagating the probabilties the
difference to problem log yes so theog
has this way mod semantics right so you
use the F semantics to propagate so so
we so I wouldn't know the answer to that
uh we can probably take that offline but
we do have uh so was as I said inspired
by Deep Pro blog we do have weighted
model counting what I just showed you so
ma Max I see so you mean fuzzy as in
this Max Min okay okay so I just showed
you a simple semiring in practice we
don't use any of those we just use them
early on while we are developing
applications
but very quickly it turns out these
fuzzier semi Rings don't really help
learn uh the model okay so the one that
we really use so I said there's the
discrete uh exe execution um there's the
probabilistic one uh and and then
finally there's the differentiable one
which is what we use for for learning
right and the one that you are probably
talking about is what we call Top C
proofs so along with each uh tupal we we
track um you know the what we call you
know up to the topk proofs which I think
Eric in the first talk referred to as I
believe W of X okay so we don't count
how many times a tuple is is was was
used or
anything yes um with respect to the
negation and saturation operations right
uh can you expand a little bit on what
your requirements for them are um for
this to
work yeah this is sort of too low level
for me to explain so I wouldn't know
I'll be happy to get you in touch with
uh the
student um you know first of all it will
be stratified negation uh but I think
you are asking me a deeper uh question
than that algebraic structure what it
test to what the negation has to
PR if it comes to me I'll let you know I
I do know exactly what you asking and
I'll I'll try to see if I can remember
okay um um there are certain
restrictions on on on all of these on
negation and saturation okay um but you
prove them once and for all when you're
defining the semi ring okay um and so
you can then use it um here so okay so
I'm not going to go too much into
further into semi Rings other than to
just say that uh the nice thing here at
least to me is that the programmer
writes as if they are programming
against a deterministic neural model
that is producing these outputs right
but under the hood you have all of these
problemistic and differentiable uh you
know reasoning happening through these
tags okay um we have applied this to a
wide range of benchmarks uh and are now
moving to even more sophisticated ones
uh in robotics and uh healthare for
explainable healthare and so on but I'll
just show you some core uh uh you know
some challenges in in the field of AI
that we started out with um these
include um you know benchmarks in uh
computer vision which have images and
video for example here this is uh this
Mugen Benchmark where the goal is given
a short video and a piece of text to
give a score between zero and one uh
that tells How likely is this text uh uh
talking about the frames in this video
right so this as you can imagine has
applications in in in video captioning
video search video recommendation and so
on right um then is we have benchmarks
in NLP as well um again fairly standard
ones um um and um and then we also have
multimodal uh benchmarks and and and
much of this these benefits of
relational the relational model uh uh
are useful here for example we extract
scene graphs from images which can be
represented as relations we extract
abstract syntax trees from in semantic
parsing which are again represented as
relations right um this is where the
rubber meets the road all of this theory
is elegant but if it doesn't work in
practice then it's not uh that it
doesn't help us right um when we started
this project many of these baselines uh
both neural and neuros symbolic were far
behind us right but by the time we got
all of this published some of them had
even crept back up ahead of us right so
this is sort of the challenge we Face
against the endtoend Deep learning
Paradigm right which is it will you know
um you know as newer neural
architectures and so on are designed
they might even outperform say the
neuros symbolic approaches
okay so um any questions before I
proceed yes maybe also right so accuracy
is one thing right but I could also see
that since you're encoding some domain
knowledge into your program right I
could see that for example you might
need like less data to learn the model
and things like that and maybe it's more
performant can yes so so great question
and and and we have all of these results
in our PDI paper PDI
20123 uh where we talk about better
interpretability so if you remember the
intermediate representation r on which
no supervision was given we can actually
look back what did it actually learn the
right representation right uh and and
the answer is yes so it is so it is more
interpretable it is more robust and
better
generalizable so and so these better
neural networks are they kind of trying
to do what you do with your structured
constraints are they trying to do that
through Network structure or are they
trying to simulate physically what you
can do in a more elegant some first of
all these are end to-end deep neural
models right like Transformers and so on
we wouldn't necessarily know what they
are trying to do but but they are
solving uh this problem let me show you
one right so this Pathfinder it was a
benchmark by I think Google research a
few years ago called path X you see that
two tiny dots and and you have to tell
whether there's a dotted path from one
to the other okay and even for a human
uh it can take up to two minutes to tell
for for some of these difficult images
whether it's actually a dotted path or
not so it's a binary classification
problem right so uh you know so the
state of the art now here is actually a
Transformer which uh I'm
sorry which uh which beats what we have
so you see for path X there's this
Transformer model which is doing even
better than ours in our case we simply
learn you know we have the rule for
computing transitive closure so once you
know which where are the two dots and
where are the edges you can use trans
you know simple these two rules to tell
whether they're reachable or not but you
don't know if their model is trying to
do something like that in the Deep
learning model directly right so we
haven't actually seen you know like for
explanations within them so so it would
be nice to see that there also some
neuros symbolic uh baselines here I mean
work that G and others have done by the
way a lot of his work has gone into this
with sentential decision diagrams and so
on in our weighted model counting that
I'm you know just ignor you know not
mentioning here but but there are other
neuros symbolic works as well uh uh
based on you know abductive reasoning
and so on that we were able to
outperform yeah so a question about the
gradient semi which was mentioned
several times today so I you understand
how it's
in in the context here because gradient
semi ring really computes the forward
derivatives which means that if you have
a network for object detection with a
million parameters you have to push
forward a million dimensional Vector
through your whole computation path and
what you really need for machine
learning is the award derivatives which
are you know linear time right so even
though mathematically the the gradient
saming is a beautiful thing it's
actually the wrong tool for machine
learning you want the back
not the
for yeah so so I think yeah I think
we'll have to talk about this more
offline sorry about that I I yeah I I
wasn't paying too close attention to the
gradient sing let's talk
more
that yeah so uh so for the first two
examples we have
to and then uh this is like after you
recog so another approach is that you
recognize and then you just write python
Su together right so why is this any
better why are you doing anything better
so here supervision is not given on the
individual Mist digits okay it's only
given on the final result yeah so but
this example is it feels a little bit
cont right so I could have done this by
doing this two-e approach examples here
we this kind of more stream approach has
a of course so so so if you had
supervision on the intermediate results
you wouldn't need scallop at all okay
you say don't right right in in none of
these benchmarks do we have intermediate
supervision even though many of them are
synthetic and you actually know the
intermediate labels so that is how we
actually you know measure whether you
know inter you know the degree of
interpretability how much has it
actually recovered the information so
I'm not showing you you know we have
heat maps all of this to show you
actually what intermediat representation
was learned and it is it it matches the
synthetic data labels
um yes okay so um you know that is you
know I'm just going to show you some fun
things here there's not much uh more I
can say here with you know so so now
what happened was in these two years
that we did this work llms and more
generally Foundation models came on the
scene and we wondered you know can we
catch up right can we somehow integrate
this into scallop and the answer
surprisingly is yes okay and this is
still open I think Joe also brought this
up you know if I understood correctly
what you saying you know so what is the
the programming you know abstraction for
say you know these generative models and
surprisingly the relational model still
works if you think of any foundation
model right it is a binary relation
which takes a prompt and and gives a
response right and these are data types
whether strings or tensors and so on are
all supported in scallop okay and it's
actually a relation not a function
because based on the temperature and so
that you use the same prompt could have
different responses right so it fit
right you know very well into scallop
and we buil this library of plugins we
now have 12 Foundation models integrated
into scallop and you can add new ones uh
very easily uh using our foreign uh
function and predicate interface um I'm
not going to go too much into these uh
uh but I can you can sort of see how we
are we have these uh curators for uh
relations um and you can use a few short
examples or you can use Chain of Thought
you can use Auto GPT uh you can even
fine-tune uh you know layers of these
models in scallop uh using again just
end to endend
supervision um in this case you know we
we break down this task into uh sort of
this in context learning which extracts
T PS uh you know which are the basic
relationships between Pairs of people
mentioned in this passage uh and then we
write a few rules in this case just
three which can compute uh the answer to
a question which is how is a particular
pair of people in this passage related
right so this is sort of showing you
multihop reasoning um uh by the way we
even have rule learning here so the
parameters don't just have to be in the
neural model but for example this
relation composition is itself noisy and
you could learn uh the weights of
individual ters of this relation right
we can extend it to Vision models as
well so here's a simple one which is
actually
a a multimodel model clip from open AI
which also provides probabilities so in
this case the the the input is an image
so it's a bound argument and the output
is the label so in this case if you give
a set of labels such as cat and dog it
will tell you the probability uh of this
image being a cat or a dog right um we
have also integrated meta segment
anything model so this in this case you
are given an image as an input and it
produces a a set of tuples with an ID of
each segment and and the tensor
representation of the segment right you
can put these all together and build
very interesting multimodal applications
in scallop so in this case here what you
see is three different models put
together to solve the problem uh from
this clever Benchmark which asks in this
case uh some some question that involves
Elementary reasoning about a scene right
in this case how many green objects are
there in the image I'm not showing you
all of the rules that we wrote in
scallop they about 100 rules that we
wrote for this particular task but we
use these three different models to
extract basic information in this case
you know doing the semantic parsing of
this question extracting segments from
this image and finally labeling each
segment uh with a piece of text right
finally we can get the answer that there
are three uh green objects in this image
okay so I'm not going to show you the
emperial results uh this work is still
under uh review um uh we have applied it
to a wide range of benchmarks including
those involving Vector databases so you
know you're having
retrieval uh and generation but also
image generation and so on right um and
you can actually run many of these
applications at this uh URL and there's
a lot more resources at this particular
you are as so thank you very much for
your attention I'll be happy to take any
[Music]
[Applause]
questions once uh